john i am having a really hard time  wrapping my head around this one like  mountain dew flaming hot cheeto  i can't imagine the taste but i don't  want to here's how it was invented elise  and i'm just thinking this is what  happened some guy was playing hours and  hours of ex  accidentally dropped a cheeto into his  you know glass of mountain dew and just  a little bit too lazy to get up and do  anything about it so decided to start  drinking it eureka a new creation that's  probably how it happened elise i bet  we'll figure that out sounds about right  yeah listen  i feel like we should blame men for all  things like this  [Laughter]  i uh i can't argue with that  i can't argue so it's our fault for  mountain dew cheetos duly noted  elise thank you very much we'll try not  to invent anything else for the rest of  the day